hello i'm brad geddes the founder a
certified knowledge the author of
advanced google adwords and the PPC
faculty chair for simply learned in this
video we're going to explain what is PPC
often known as pay-per-click paid search
or even SEM for search engine marketing
with PPC advertisers can reach the
audience they want when they want and
often at the budget they want it's one
of the most efficient forms of digital
marketing and I'm here to explain the
basics behind this extraordinary channel
PPC is an auction-based system where
various advertisers place bids to target
and reach users online when you're
looking to find users from paid search
or from display advertisements
businesses of any size can leverage this
channel to reach interested prospects
discover how PPC can drive valuable and
measurable traffic without wasting
valuable advertising spent in this video
you will learn to define paid search
advertising also known as PPC
advertising distinguish paid search
results from organic search results
explain how display advertising can
complement paid search advertising list
situations when PPC could benefit a
digital marketing strategy and list the
multiple steps of the PPC cycle
so PPC is really the act of buying
traffic on search engines such as Bing
or Google ascom Yahoo so forth and for a
lot of companies this is their primary
metric for new customer acquisition
you've ever done a search before on
Google or Bing you've seen ads or
sponsor results at the top of the pages
these are the ads were talking about the
search ads these are often the very
first part of a search engine result
page that a user sees when conducting a
search now often advertisers want to
know how big a channel really is and how
much traffic can they get from any
advertising medium when we look at
search search encompasses a little more
than 6 billion search queries every
single day the largest search engines
are Bing Yahoo and google and the goal
then is to take some of these search
queries when they're relevant to your
business and bring traffic to your
website so you can get customers your
ads can also be shown across the Display
Network now the Display Network our
other sites that show ads on them that
are partnered with Google or Bing to
display advertisements so this is
commonly new sites it may be things even
social sites such as Facebook and these
sites then are places that you can show
your ads on them that aren't searched
but are more akin to banner type ad you
seems now these may be text ads maybe
images that might even be video ads and
you can choose to have them displayed
based upon words use your interests I'm
contextual targeting methods and even
things such as remarketing which is
where someone does a particular behavior
on your website already and then you
show ads back across this network to
them so for instance you might be
looking at vacation getaway packages and
then you're thinking about it
considering it but then you leave the
site now you're over here reading about
a new computer something totally
different on a different website but
because you did specific actions on
their site they might show you ads then
on this third-party site about getaway
packages and so when you look across the
Display Network
there's a lot of different very specific
ways you can reach users that are not
quite search searches a very relevant
base industry but it comes pretty close
to search when you combine all the
options and so by looking at both search
and display across paid search you can
be incredibly specific of when you want
a user to see your ad where they're
based and then what conditions are
involved that make an ad display to any
one user now paid search is an
auction-based system so every time a
search happens then in auctions run to
decide where your ads will be displayed
now paid search is called paid search
because you do pay for the traffic
however you only pay for traffic that
comes to your website so it's free to
have your ad displayed you only pay when
you get traffic from a search engine to
your website there's a lot of targeting
capabilities in you can use to make sure
you're only putting your message in
front of relevant users so one is
geography
you can have your ads shown in a
specific city and entire metro state or
even multiple countries you can pick
what times a day or days of the week you
want your ads displayed you can choose
to have different ads on mobile devices
then on desktop devices and you can even
pick individual websites or ad slots
where you want your ads displayed
there's a lot of targeting capabilities
you can utilize to make sure only
relevant users are seeing your ads so we
sort of look at how search ads works
with various business types in the
e-commerce environment you often see the
ads or focus more on pricing on shipping
that's what users and an e-commerce
experience are looking for when they're
trying to buy products online we examine
an industry like lead generation often
your focus from your ad standpoint is
direct response advertising or getting
an actual lead from each individual
click so often you'll see the
description line to the bottom part of
an ad
is really focused on calls-to-action cow
was for a free consultation fill out a
form to get quotes for your business in
local businesses often your ads are
focused on your locality to fact you're
local and that users can easily get to
your business you can even do things
with search ads such as put your phone
number directly into the ads users can
call you from a search result or a
mobile phone start the conversion
process without even leaving a search
result page and there's a lot of four
ways you can choose to use paid search
to advertise informational queries are
great to you to reach users higher in
the buying funnel and so with paid
search depending on your business type
there's a lot of different ways which
you'll approach this medium of
advertising so we look at the overall
PPC process it first it first starts by
you choosing keywords and then you write
ads for those words and next you'll set
bids how much you're willing to pay for
any one click the what happens someone
does a search your ad gets displayed now
only if the user clicks on the ad then
do you pay the engine and then you get
traffic to your site then paid search is
wonderful because it's so measurable so
you can measure your revenue and actual
conversions from paid search and use
that to decide how you want to use your
keywords and targeting options and then
also set your bids and so paid search
can be used largemont ways one way is
direct response where your goal is to
acquire customer from every single ad
click that's a common advertising method
you might use it for branding purposes
we want to increase your visibility and
awareness for your company many studies
have shown that when ads are commonly in
the top results for words they increase
unaided and aided brand awareness for a
company so we think of kind of use cases
for different company tights we have
online retailers so they may use a
search engine for direct response then
they might use display advertising to
increase the brand of their business
give local businesses they use online
to target a local populace and then make
sure people knows areas can find them
call their company and then get users
from that you have often larger
businesses they might use adjust for
brand awareness throughout the search
and Display Network might even have
maybe a new site and you've just created
a mobile version of your new site using
paid search to make sure people can find
you on mobile devices and increase your
awareness so a lot of friends use cases
of why you'd want to use page search for
your business now before you really
start though you should understand what
does your company or division do so do
you have different product lines
what are your product lines do each of
these product lines have different goals
to them who's your primary audience
who's your target market for your
products and services do you need to
reach different audiences with different
sets of ads or keywords what are you
trying to sell or promote what do you
want people to do from your ads on your
website you want to buy something watch
a video download a white paper subscribe
to your emails and then what results
would you like to see what would you
consider a successful advertising
campaign so by first understanding these
basics of your business then as you look
through all the paid search options that
we're going to go through throughout
this video series you can see which ones
are most appropriate or how you might
use them differently than others based
upon your business metrics now one of
the real advantages of paid search
though is the inventory sources you can
show up on search results YouTube Gmail
Maps Bing Maps or Google Maps and across
a two-plus million other websites you
can also choose where and the buying
funnel you want to reach users so you
might want to increase the number people
who are aware of your company and their
interest level in your products you
might want to just reach users who are
in that consideration phase of course of
your direct response you just want to
reach people in the buy phase and if
your focus is on lifetime visitor values
you can use other tech
such as remarketing to increase lifetime
visitor values so when you look at your
business and you look at the whole
buying funnel you can use paid search to
direct users based upon where they are
on that buying funnel and what your
goals are for advertising with paid
search we have the 3 R's reach relevance
return on investment which make this a
level playing field for businesses of
any size with reach you might be a small
business targeting to just a few zip
codes you might be an international
business whose company multiple
countries targeting multiple countries
we have relevance people are already
looking for you they're typing in
keywords so ads and your website offers
are highly relevant to users and of
course because it's so measurable you
can make sure that you are getting good
returns from your paid search so it
doesn't matter if you're a small
business a mid-sized business an
enterprise company if you're involved in
direct response or branding paid search
has options which can help you reach
those goals and play with big companies
or small companies regardless of of your
resource capabilities so some important
things to remember murid standpoint your
advertising on search results which are
more than 6 billion queries per day you
can advertise across Display Network
which is more than 1 trillion
impressions a month you can show your
ads across multiple devices and even
have different ads shown on mobile
devices versus desktops you can pick
exactly where in the entire world your
ads are really going to show up now
relevance is another important
measurement here you can choose words
that describe your business so you can
pick exactly when an ad is shown and so
only when someone's looking for you
they're already the warm leads are
looking for you will your ads be
displayed now PPC is an auction based
system so you're going to set bids for
what you're going to pay for click now
you do only pay when someone comes to
your site so by using analytics and it's
a basic math you can make sure that
you're setting bids so as you get clicks
and
for your site that you're getting enough
customers that it's profitable for you
to use paid search as a channel to
increase how many customers you're
getting from your search marketing
efforts
you